[Música]
spectrum todas las personas con el
síndrome de tourette piensan igual
me molesta que las personas se ríen de
mis tics tres dos uno vamos
divertidos
cualquier persona
[Risas]
tener relaciones sexuales
en la noche
digan la palabra n si es un tic yo
diablos
Vete al [ __ ]
lo que siento pero la mayoría de las
veces solo sale de algún lugar de mi
cerebro que no tengo idea
es los más cómodos
tres dos uno vamos
aquí
a la hora de encontrar a alguien
vaya mucho más fácil me siento muy
afortunada llevo Casi 6 años con mi
novio cuando salimos por primera vez fue
porque fuimos amigos mucho tiempo antes
el conocía muy bien la gravedad de mis
tics y porque vio mis tics probablemente
en su peor y mejor momento incluso
cuando salía con él antes de estar
juntos soy muy franca sobre mi síndrome
desde el inicio porque descubrí que es
casi como una
prueba de fuego Pero mis tics hacen que
las personas que están a mi alrededor
sean mejores personas hay personas que
son más inclusivas y comprensivas
[Risas]
muchas personas no quieren parecer
incomprensibles Así que encuentran
alguna otra razón para decírtelo por lo
que sé puede que hayan roto conmigo a
causa de mí
porque Dinos porque estás a algo
pero los entrenadores
oportunidades en mi camino porque no me
importa nada estoy viviendo mi vida así
que no me arrepiento de nada de lo que
hice No he tenido muchas oportunidades
que perder pero definitivamente influyen
lo que soy capaz de hacer por ejemplo
nado en la escuela y a veces tengo que
parar y tomar un descanso porque mis
tics son tan grave
a contratar pero espero volver a la
escuela online porque también me vi
obligada
y el sonido pero
Vete al [ __ ] mucho
[Música]
Ojalá hubieran nacido Sin tu red
3 2 1
lo tengo desde los 7 años ha sido duro y
me operaron del cerebro por ello mejoré
un 50% porque Yo solía moverme sin parar
o temblar al caminar la única forma en
que podía sentarme era si estaba
realmente drogado fumando hierba todo el
día después de la cirugía dejé de fumar
durante 4 meses pero me gustaría tener
una vida sin este síndrome sin tener que
tomar pastillas o con tics
incontrolables se lo he dicho a las
personas
me convirtió en la persona que soy hoy
sé mucho más sobre mí misma sobre mi
salud mental y soy socialmente
consciente de la persona que soy creo
que los pros superan definitivamente a
los contras hay muchos contra
físicamente para mí pero prefiero por el
bien de la humanidad y por el amor a las
personas prefiero lidiar con esto para
poder estar ahí para todos los demás
estoy muy contento de haber sido
introducido la comunidad
en el que muestro los talentos de las
personas con síndrome de tourette Cuando
hacemos algo que realmente nos gusta
hacer para mí solía hacer cuando estaba
leyendo libros cuando estaba cantando
Bailando
creativas es porque es el único momento
en que podemos estar tranquilos
[Risas]